was wir haben eltern ich sehe schwarz
für deutschlands zukunft auch sogar
damit gemacht herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen leute ich hab heute wieder
meine schwester war das letzte wie gut
meine schwester ist durch angekommen
hatte deswegen gibt es heute eine
fortsetzung und zwar dachte ich mir dass
wir uns beide male zusammen queens
tecdax anschauen du bist ja jemand der
sich durchaus vermissen mit ihm
auseinandergesetzt hat man ja du lebst
hast halt man muss dazu sagen dass ich
nicht so jemand bin der ich mach das
ganze ironisch gut dramatische pause und
ja ich würde sagen jetzt fangen wir an
mit dem video twin stick talks
[Musik]
auf wunsch erstellt
wenn keiner kommt immerhin aber ist ja
cool ist ja nicht könnte es im
kunstkeller mitten im coolen style alter
zeitgleich und dann noch die gehälter
auf das neue ding
[Musik]
bruder also diese moves werde das sagen
nicht schneller gemacht meinte
mittlerweile gibt es auch heute
es gibt z suche auf einige hatte
deutschen sie einfach wirklich gezielt
schlecht des rektors machen weil sie
wissen damit dass damit eine solche
komplexen es kommen also er meint das
ernst
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sein kopf ist wie so ein diesen
stabilisator für kameras kennt ja diese
dinger die man so hay wain kann so
wackelt die kaffeestube hier also pro
was was macht er da auch der bassist für
eine kamera perspektive ist uns wichtig
was sie trennt was entfernt einmal dinge
kann man auf den boden zu legen
[Musik]
ist ein joint heute gerade hallo hallo
was zu haben
ich sehe schwarz für deutschlands
zukunft auch so gut geworden
max kaplan nicht
ich hatte mir so meine ufo fast 12 das
war so schlimm leute dann aus wenn ich
2016 2018 oder 19
doch eben 2019 also klingt das kwa hatte
so ihre ufer 361 phase keine eltern
hatten aber ein don't like und dann hat
sie so genial story gepostet alles gute
zum geburtstag machen lassen
sorry aber das ist aber sie sind nicht
so sollten sie diese was könnte die sie
zu hause sollte sie in jako katalog des
gangster steht
kann sie aber schon ein bisschen mehr
feiern oder hsv geht das gar nicht ist
es gar nicht so auskennt ist schon fast
lustig und lustig weiters kommt das
original sagt fleisch auf den sport talk
kommt von westen her da hatte ich nicht
immer ja ich hatte ein bisschen spot
schön aber kein plan wo das herkommt
weiß sie wenn ihr wissen woher das kommt
weiß dass irgendwo herkommen kann ich
nicht schlimm was gerade nicht an ihr
aber der song oder soja ist es von der
youtube kann man am besten mit
aber wer ist kann man kann trotzdem
bildet wenn ich das die bayern und sie
heißt jetzt weitet sie kater lassen wenn
ihr den job verstanden habe
hatte
wer mag ich das einzige ist es auf jeden
dass er das einfach nicht gut ist ritter
das einstige spice aber irgendwie ich
muss sagen bei den anderen im team
gesehen dass ich mir sogar die will ich
ja etwas und den richtspruch
sie würden nicht helfen sie ist mir
sympathisch man kann sich unterhalten
weil ich da habe ich gar keinen bock
entweder sozusagen ja und der hat ja
klar ich muss eigentlich muss ich nutzen
korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch denke
aber das klang in diesem song über keine
sorgen über die ministerin
ich will diesen
[Musik]
ich sage da nicht so wie aber ist es
aber was auch diese alien ist eine
person dass sie nur die nummer zwei
[Gelächter]
wir haben einfach leute so um 8 uhr wenn
unsere mutter eigentlich fernsehen
schaut ins wohnzimmer gepackt und sie
ist jetzt irgendwo im haupt so ein held
[Musik]
das war sowieso nicht so ein cover von
apache gemacht habt ihr was mit absicht
ich glaube dass ein richtiges jetzt
haben wirklich warum zahlen einmal etwa
[Musik]
223 regieren ich würde nur probieren
zweimal 22 dieses glück zu probieren
fünf freunde zweimal 52
es ist wichtig und diese er geht nur
über ibiza ab erste zahlen
wir brauchen leute kriminalität ist in 4
ich glaube meine 446 für kriminalität
fünf freunde
ja aber er klingt gut aber er geht nicht
so sehr ab dass jetzt im schneidersitz
verlassen wird
so müsste auch mal ein bisschen chillen
ist ein bisschen das jetzt folgen die
das meine so bin ich gern alles passiert
gerade die wissen gar nicht dass es so
abgehen kann
in sachen drogen mit ultra titel
wenn ich hier gefallen hat ihm ein karat
hat gerne auch die kommentare ab wer
bock auf mehr wie seine schwester habt
hier gibt's einfach ich vorgeschlagen
dass wir hier oben könnt ihr einen kanal
abonniert sehr vernünftige entscheidung
muss ich sagen
während an der stelle raus haut rein das
gut